avec la deuxième vague de covile 19 les
hôpitaux s'organise tant bien que mal au
nouvel hôpital civil de strasbourg les
services de réanimation
habituellement très sollicité en cette
saison redoute la saturation
malgré l'expérience acquise lors de la
première vague de qu'ovide et face au
manque d'infirmières le personnel
soignant craint de revivre la crise du
printemps dernier aidez nous à éviter le
tsunami parce que clairement c'était une
situation qu'on veut pas revivre le
personnel qui soit médical ou
paramédical n'est pas sorti indemne de
la première vague de la première crise
on aimerait éviter d'aller dans des
situations qu'annoncé on s'est trouvés
qui sait qu'ils étaient des situations
on va dire inhumaine pour tout le monde
on connaît doucement on commence à
connaître un petit peu la prise en
charge et les spécificités du co lead
donc de toute façon dans la page choix
et on est prêt à affronter cette
deuxième vague
on est dans les meilleures conditions
pour ce qui est du matériel pour ce qui
est du personnel
c'est là où le bât blesse ou est ce que
il ya une dette avant même cet épisode
co-lead tous les postes infirmiers sont
pas pourvus même constat à paris où
certains hôpitaux ont annulé les
vacances de leurs personnels à commencer
par les congés de la toussaint dans cet
établissement du nord de paris le
service des maladies infectieuses et
désormais entièrement dédié aux patients
atteints du coït 19
comme tant d'autres l'hôpital fait face
à une nette accélération des admissions
depuis une semaine avait cessé de se
battre
certainement beaucoup moins de moyens en
termes humains puisque l'épidémie tous
de manière homogène toute la france donc
on va pas compter sur des collègues du
sud ou du nord
on va se débrouiller en interne ce qui
est le plus difficile c'est de
s'apercevoir qu'on a
qu'on a eues entre les entrées la
première saison la deuxième un
épuisement et que beaucoup de ces deux
professionnels soignants n'ont pas eu le
temps de récupérer
depuis une semaine c'est une
accélération de la montée donc on était
sur le monte des patients qu'aux vide
qui était inéluctable mais lente et la
petit s'accélère et ce qu'il veut dire
qu'on risque de devoir rentrer dans un
processus de déprogrammation plus
important est donc plus complexe à
mettre en oeuvre
en visite dans un centre hospitalier de
pontoise emmanuel macron a tenu à
rappeler à la population l'importance du
rôle du personnel soignant dans cette
crise sanitaire
il nous faut faire corps avec l'ensemble
des pc des personnels soignants en mars
avril on a tous pris conscience de ce
qui se passait nous avons tous eu peur
nous avons tous vu compris le rôle
qu'avait toutes celles et ceux qui nous
soignent tout au long de l'année
la france entière a applaudi à 20 heures
il faut que nous reprenions pleinement
conscience de ce rôle et je le dis avec
beaucoup de force
avec l'arrivée de l'hiver et de la
grippe saisonnière
les services réanimation pourrait
connaître de fortes tensions ces
prochaines semaines le personnel
soignant lui et abou ils comptent
manifester sa colère et témoigner de son
épuisement lors de la mobilisation
intersyndicale du 28 octobre prochain